[Music]
this is the big Western comic complaint
I was with an American comic he's like
we're cancel culture is insane the other
day a mob came after me a mob on Twitter
comedian verdas is known for his sharp
wit and observational humor showcased in
landing his brand new stand-up special
on Netflix Doss has made a name for
himself both in India and
internationally but not without
controversy a recent routine that spread
on social media created a fair degree of
outrage in his home country and even led
to criminal charges but it hasn't
tripped him up or slowed him down as our
Jamie wax found out on a visit with the
comic at the Hollywood improv in Los
Angeles
I'm too Indian for the west but too
Western for India does that make sense
to anybody
verdas is the definition of a global
tassel in Indian that I would study to
be a doctor
no but like I'm Indian enough well I
would never use a white doctor
I think Indian people are amongst the
best storytellers in the world and I
think it's because we
at least at a fiction level and at a
literary level we unapologetically
access emotion in our storytelling so I
I feel like our emotion makes it to the
page a lot quicker has anybody ever been
to India
but if you haven't been you must go
because your Jobs have
born in India and raised partly in
Nigeria the art of telling jokes and
stories came from his family I love cool
stories because of my grandfather I
called him Baba I think what I learned
from him is that the greatest
storytellers in the world
make you feel like they're remembering a
story instead of telling a story you
almost feel like they were recollecting
it for themselves and an audience
happened to be in the room it's a Memory
it's a memory for sure I think comedy
serves greatest for storytelling because
if you measure the breadth of a human
being's life
I'd venture to say that for 80 of Our
Lives we feel like idiots you know we
feel idiotic
after his stand-up took off he tried his
hand in Bollywood
Mr Bhatia
and even landed roles in U.S Network
sitcoms hi no we don't need Nemo
magazines I'm not getting scammed again
but he's best known for his
cross-culturally hilarious stand-up with
a definite Indian twist like like if you
came to me and you're like there's a
college kid missing in the forest do you
know what I would do immediately
I would call my cousins back home in
India
because now there is a vacancy in that
College
his latest Netflix special Landing is
now streaming worldwide you are an
incredibly contemporary comedian you
comment on Modern things yes and I do
think that there is a Global Perspective
now like for the first time in history
you and me we just went through the same
pandemic so there's never been a better
time for me to talk to you America or
you England or you Australia about you
and me in the same breath so This Global
platform has really meant something in
your career absolutely but but it's also
meant something to me as a consumer when
I watch Richard Pryor talk to me about
Peoria Illinois or I watch a Dave
Chappelle talk to me about Ohio I may
not know too many things about those
places but I get to go on those Journeys
with them why can't I take you back to
Mumbai why can't I take you back to
Delhi and you may never have been but
maybe Delhi is your Ohio so come with me
does this place hold special memories
for you my first ever spot in the U.S
was here and I didn't know you that you
could get free water so I went to the
bar and I like bought a bottle of water
and I did the the spot and then the
bartender was like you're a comic just
tell me you're a comic and I'll give you
water next time I didn't know you got
free water dasa's humor is often rooted
in deep Frank perhaps blunt honesty as
he sees it now in the west you've had
privilege for years you've taken a
taking offense to another level like
Americans can get offended on other
people's behalf
so it's a very American thing I'm
offended for you
what you went through is so stressful
I'm going to take the day off
you seem genuinely yourself when you are
up there speaking your truths whatever
this version of myself is and it's taken
work like if you look at my first
Netflix special it's like hyper and
talking to everybody and playing to the
big room and then uh this one is kind of
chilled out yeah you know yeah your
energy has has definitely shifted or
matured but it seems to match as you say
where we are in society right now I
I've waited for this generation to come
along for a really long time here's why
I think your generation might save the
world you have zero emotional retention
you must articulate every experience
made experience and receive validation
for the experience before you have
completed the experience
this generation is redefining Fame and
stardom all together where like the more
real you are the more we'll get behind
you I come from in India that has the
largest working population under 30 on
the planet but still listens to 75 year
old Leaders with 150 year old ideas I
come
he tested that theory and stirred up
controversy when he famously finished a
set with a poem he wrote called I come
from two Indians I come from in India
where we take pride in being vegetarians
and we had run over the farmers who grow
our vegetables
the video made headlines the comedian
was accused of vilifying his home
country on the BBC home page big
headline that said comedian polarizes
the nation
do you know how badly you have to before
the British say that you divided India
I think the first thing that I wrote was
a joke about it I was like how can I
write a joke that everybody laughs at
and puts me as a at the center of
that joke where no matter how you feel
about
my content we're both laughing I was
called a terrorist on three different
news channels on The Prime Time news
that is an interesting conversation with
your mother that evening
just watching the news like remember how
you said you don't know how to describe
what I do for a living
no matter how you felt about it you were
like okay this guy's a now let's
laugh about this and let's move forward
so I think the minute I wrote that first
joke it honored everybody I never got
any feedback from any terrorist groups I
promise you
I never got a phone call hey Veer Isis
huge fans love your work
did it hurt for a while did it sting no
I think any
if you're able to tell people about your
problems on Netflix
[Laughter]
pretty good for vir Das life is about
looking ahead not back I hope to get to
a point in my life where there's time
for retrospect I'm certainly not there
yet I see too much in front of me and
I'm too excited by it my name is veertas
it was an honor performing for you
tonight
for CBS Saturday morning Jamie West Los
Angeles